here we go okay um I think I got it done
got it taken care of should be starting
here in a second
okay God man there we go okay OBS was
being like a dig I had to uninstall it
and reinstall it again like thank you oh
yes you're the easiest software to work
with when you work but hopefully you
guys can hear me fine um let me uh let
me adjust the volume on this or the
things on this little bit oh my god man
this track holy [ __ ] hold on a second
hon it's like it let me find this for
you guys
oh my god let me find this crap for you
guys beat on this track is mmm man what
make sure this is the right one oh my
god listen to this listen to this guys
listen to that song click on that link
that song is mmm anyway what's going on
guys welcome to comics and coffee our
weekly Q&A where I feel you guys in and
talk to you guys and answer questions
that you have about me or comics or so
on and so forth um also make sure you
guys check out comics a cutter not
conference coffee make sure you guys
check out Rob explains what's going on I
don't mind waving which you guys check
out Rob explains I have a video on there
right now about the different lightsaber
colors what they mean and they'll video
be a video coming up tomorrow about why
people loved heroes so much because
heroes is coming out this week so I'm
really really psyched about that so
we'll be doing like a bunch of hero
stuff um but yeah that track is same and
it's like like I need to I need to talk
to whoever well you find out who made it
and see if they'll let me use it in a
video but um if you guys are interested
here is here's what i'm listening to at
the moment you guys know i always try to
give you guys a rundown on the songs i'm
listening to or like what i'm listening
to when i do my livestream QA at least i
have recently anyway and so since
YouTube allowed us to start posting
links so there you go anyway for those
of you guys who were curious Rob
explains ah man you'll find a link for
the for the for Rob explains down in the
description but in case you don't feel
like scrolling down there here is Rob
explains there you go yeah I'm really
psyched about heroes yeah heroes is
really really good um but yeah I'm gonna
be going through and em say like why
people love heroes so much who's Matt
Parkman who's Hiro Nakamura i think i
might make videos on that like you know
what the circumstances that led to them
gaining their powers and so on but
yeah like that man this beat oh my god
man i see i love these hip-hop mixes Oh
questions questions questions questions
questions am I excited for for the Luke
Cage series yes I am hyper Luke Cage I'm
glad we're back doing this again because
we missed it last week and it feels like
it's been forever but yeah I'm really
really excited for the Luke Cage series
I think the loot cave series the great
thing about Netflix is they can make
this shows so dark they can make them
much darker than you would normally see
with with basically like any kind of you
know film coming out and that's that's
the great thing with that's the great
thing with with Netflix is you can get
away with a lot more because it's a
subscription service it's not network
television you know and so they can they
can do all different kinds of things my
coffee is was water I don't have any
water with me right now I probably have
to get some here in a second but oh yeah
you do guys do only have audio and left
your home on second on a sec let me fix
that let me fix that audio forced
microphone
okay the audio should balance here in a
second guys but anyway so let me let me
grab some water real quick I'll be right
back you guys
oh man okay we are back um Deacon sundry
was fun like geek and sundry was really
really awesome I will say this like like
when I when I was in LA like it was it
was overwhelming you know it was how
would I have K could be hilarious if I
did this in my tighty whities ya know
like i am when i was in Los Angeles like
I'm from giving I'm from Kentucky like
I'm in Lexington Kentucky and so here
like like things are so small if there's
no sound that it's probably on you guys
has anybody having problems hearing me
you guys should be able to hear me fine
but let me know if you guys can't hear
me um anyway um I'm from Lexington
Kentucky you know and so going to a city
as hugest Los Angeles was tough like you
know it was it was overwhelming you know
like it was really really overwhelming
and so I you know I it took a little bit
of getting used to you know and there
was one point where like I ended up in
the hood like I was I was going through
and the audio is really really bit like
is it really laggy like until like a ton
of people start complaining i think i
think we'll be okay but I was anyway I
was going through and I ended up on like
Crenshaw Boulevard and ok you can hear
me fun ok sounds fine cool ok cool
awesome and it's just that one guy
probably has a really bad connection or
something like that um Kevin Smith frame
sounds like you on his podcast but I was
going through it ended up on like
crenshaw boulevard and and that was like
that was crazy because I was like well
I'm turn around i'll just make a u-turn
right over here at like this gas station
and they were like these really
seedy-looking you know I just group of
guys and I was like
no I know nothing about this town I have
no idea where I'm at you know and it's
not that I thought they were gonna do
anything to me is that I just didn't
know what was going on and so I was like
okay so I just turned around and I and I
bailed out I was like I've got to get
out of here cuz you know for me I don't
like being in town so you know as big as
that that have so many different people
you know because you don't know what
those people are going to do you don't
know what they think you know it's you
know I kind of felt out of my element
you know and so I turn around I'm web
but you know I finally made my way back
to the hotel but um but yes so um let's
see a favorite Marvel multiverse well
there's really only one multiverse but
which by the way guys you'll find like
the anime stuff is going to be overrun
Rob explains now but yeah like I mean my
favorite universe in the multiverse is
probably from secret wars right now
anyway it's probably what was I guess my
favorite character is old man Logan my
favorite universe is probably the
Infinity Gauntlet universe that the
universe is really really cool like I
really like that idea so um Deadpool
Thanos yeah Deadpool vs. Thanos is
hilarious like I it's basically like a
big fight they basically like fighting
over mistress death and it's it's funny
like we're definitely going to cover
that story once it finishes like it
looks amazing hey Rob first time here
well welcome and congratulations thank
you for showing up here like I hope you
enjoy the whole comics of coffee thing
but yeah thanks for being here Rob whose
side are you on for civil war iron man
i'm always on Iron Man side where we're
in LA did you stay I stayed actually I'm
it to adjust the audio real quick adjust
the sound of the audio let me turn this
up a bit Mike boost this my kind of loud
guys be ready
okay um I stayed at the ramada inn and
listen him it is a city starts with a
beat it's like a summer of the search
with Abby and I contra what it's called
now but um Oh God anyway i can what the
city was called but it was like a suburb
of LA and it was it was cool my hotel
was actually right across the street
from geek and sundry so here's a geek &
sundry thing so here's what that was
that was super fun um I can't really
tell you guys what was going on I think
they had me sign an NDA not as closure
agreement so i can't really like to tell
you guys what happened but um the the
show is going to be cool like i'm really
gonna enjoy it um i will say this the
geek and sundry crowd they're cool like
they were really really fun to hang out
with there was this one dude named
Hector and Hector was really fun Hector
was a really Lily cool guy which by the
way he has a channel called a superhero
news the superhero new show let me
double check to make sure that's right
but um let me link you guys to it real
quick uh yeah superhero nooters he also
do the guys so do you guys a link we
have the superhero news show is what
it's called and there's there's a leak
right there it's actually really cool
like they they do all kinds of different
news and stuff like that and there was a
really cool group of guys like i really
really like talking to hector he was
funny like if anything has caught the
live stream of me playing um what wasn't
playing um heroclix with the geek &
sundry crowd like he was a guy who was
dressed as Robin no I didn't meet what
Weeden I wish I had but I didn't get a
chance to meet you most powerful County
book weapon ooh I see the anti-life
equation um the infiniti comments really
strong because its destructive you know
but why would you need to destroy
anything if you have the ability to
force people to do what you want them to
you and so like that i think the
anti-life equation is is ridiculous
which by the way if you guys are curious
about the anti-life equation that's
covered under my dark side video i think
but what I'm thinking about doing
something that I'm just kind of kicking
around I may or may not do it is I'm
thinking about launching a series called
coming book concepts where it basically
focuses on like elements of comics like
weapons you know the Infinity Gauntlet
the heart of the universe the Cosmic
Cube stuff like that and we
talked about those things over the years
but it'll be a series of videos it
really won't need to be any longer than
five minutes or so but it'll just
basically tell you like here are what
these things are here's here's what they
do here's why they're important you know
here's why they matter someone and so
forth and I thought about doing that you
know with DC and so on and so forth yeah
bill finger is finally getting credit
which is about time for those of you
guys who don't know bill finger was
one-half of the creative group behind
bob kane but for decades decades and
decades like Bill Finger never got
credit for creating for yeah basically
creating Batman like he never got credit
for it it was always Bob Kane and so you
know it's kind of like it's kind of one
of those things that a lot of Batman
fans just didn't like like hardcore
Batman fans knew that bill finger had
like a major hand in creating Batman but
he was always just kind of robbed and so
now he's finally getting that
recognition so um let's see Michael
Bendis writing a Batman sir I don't know
Brian Michael Bendis is writing a Batman
story but that sounds awesome like I
would definitely read it um let's see
who do you think would win digo Cooper's
I'm not touching that I mean I'm not
touching but we know Goku would win so
um hey well when are you going to what
are you going to do an infinity War part
two I want to see how it ends so we'll
do infinity war once we get closer to
the release date of infinity war like
we'll get back to that having said that
I have I have something very important
like very significant coming down the
line it involves one of dc's most like
onic characters that's not the
definitive Superman I'm still working on
that but it involves Superman and it
involves doomsday and it involves kind
of a hangout with the two of them with a
party and they fight and they dance and
to enter one leaves so I guess none
neither leaves I don't know but anyway
so I think I guess I'll take it I think
you guys are like I'm gonna have fun
have fun making it so um hey Rob do you
reach age me I've never read teenage
Ninja Turtles comics I have never read
heroes comes out on the twenty-fourth of
this month so it comes out in four days
now I've never read Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles uh Supergirl thoughts I think
Supergirl has potential to be good but I
think it also has some potential to be
really campisi here's a problem to see
they're gonna be walking a tightrope
with Supergirl they're going to have to
ride
a way to where it doesn't feel like it's
a show it doesn't feel like a lifetime
special it doesn't feel like it puts
them in down and says like women are
just the greatest thing ever but it also
doesn't feel like it is you know
ingratiating itself to man and saying
that like women aren't necessarily
asking this man you know but it has to
it has to make sure that people feel
connected to the show you know I don't
want to watch a show and and then be
like women are better than men in every
facet you know because that's not what
feminism is but I also don't want it to
to be a show where I feel like it's
pointless or that is campy or stupid
Supergirl has a great history in DC
Comics and there were a lot of fans love
her character you know I'm hoping that
they translate that into the show and
they bring that that significance of her
character into the show having said that
um I don't even know when the show airs
to be honest and that pitiful like I
don't even know when this show airs so
who is the most powerful character in
the Marvel Universe the most powerful
character it was it's arguable um
there's like the Living Tribunal or I
guess the one above all which is the
end-all be-all but that's the other
thing I'm thinking about doing I'm
probably gonna launch a series called
omega-level mutant or beyond omegat like
I think I might go through the
characters who were beyond Omega level
and then Omega level mutants but there's
one kid who has the power to mimic the
powers of anybody up to and including
the Living Tribunal and I think maybe
even the one above all I'm not a hundred
percent sure but yeah he was nigh
unstoppable by the time yeah it was nuts
how ridiculously powerful he was but um
let's see uh what's your favorite comic
book TV show um hmm
probably arrow no probably flash I think
flash is pretty solid right after that
you start getting into but after that
you start you start getting into things
like you know shield you start getting
into arrow you start getting into
daredevil different things like that you
know it's it really kind of kind of
debates um favorite omega-level mutant
um frankly Richards like I'm all I've
always been a big fan of Frank well he's
beyond Omega level so i guess favorite
omega-level mutant will probably be Jean
Grey which one of the way yes Phoenix
Dark Phoenix dog is coming probably
coming next week the problem is like
there's all this stuff finishing right
now the secret wars and yeah so what
we'll see what's up um let's see mood
night needs to show up in the punisher
Netflix show now he doesn't need to you
don't want you don't want that to be you
don't want to feel like spider-man 3
what you have so much going on that
there's it's pandemonium and nothing
makes any sense like I don't nobody
wants to deal with that let's see do you
think cap will die in civil war yes
thoughts on Tom Holland uh I mean I
don't know much I don't really see his
character act so I don't know how well
he'll betray spider-man but I think
we'll do a good enough job let's see
Call of Duty or battlefield a
battlefield I used to be a hardcore call
of duty fan like I did game battles and
everything but after a while I was kind
of got tired of it and I stopped that
stuff lying i just got burned out lost
interest that being said i usually just
watch other call duty players so i'll
watch the mark of J and someone I'll
watch the local Patriots like that when
he uploads called it occasionally but
I'll watch that kind of stuff where was
hoping Civil War Planet Hulk was taking
place there's apocalypse Omega level
we'll see okay here's the kicker with
Omega level guys and we'll talk about
that in our first video like well we
will outline what Omega level is and I
think what we'll just keep that as a
constant theme like it'll literally be a
section of a video that will always be
the same throughout every single
omega-level video Omega level is there's
there's two types of Omega level mutants
there's people who were confirmed to be
Omega level and there's people who
haven't but that we know are
you know like you know storm for example
was confirmed to be on Omega level
mutant Jean Grey was confirmed to be an
Omega level muni as far as I know
magneto was never confirmed to be an
omega-level mutant but we know he is
just because of everything that he's
capable of apocalypse with all his power
and all his abilities I think he's I
don't know if it's ever been confirmed
that he was on that good level although
it probably has strife is an omega-level
mutant the twin of cable there's there's
a lot of characters out there that are
Omega level you know mr. M is like a
beyond Omega level character you know it
really it's really kind of weird when
you get into that territory thoughts on
jessica jones i think jessica jones is
going to be a really good TV show bindus
wrote alias he wrote the original series
that introduced jessica jones and from
what you've been saying the show is
incredible like it is so close to the
original content that it's absolutely
mind-blowing and so I'm really hyped
about it um let's see any of any
opinions of the DC you fail in DC is not
failing it's not feeling by a long shot
don't be like that the dcu is DC you is
fine it's all look guys DC has different
names different catches different stuff
like that disregard the title DC you and
go with the books that you like it's
really all comes down to so um favorite
DC characters that's a tough one um I
like Superman during Superman truth like
I like this Superman truth he's a really
cool character I like me know that he's
he's very weak compares to the way that
he used to be and I think it changes it
really changed his perspective of the
world in terms of how he views things
how he views himself in that world I
think it brought a more down the ground
level in terms of his powers that I
think is a really cool concept Jim
Gordon Batman is another guy he's your
everyday run-of-the-mill cop do the nae
nae I'm not doing the Naenae he's your
everyday one of the mill cop that was
thrust into impossible circumstances you
know Jim Gordon Batman comes out of
Batman end game and we'll talk about Jim
Gordon Batman when we finish in game but
it comes directly out of in-game and it
will you know his character I think is a
really cool take on the character a
Batman of course Bruce Wayne is coming
back because Jim Gordon Batman is just
not selling as well as Bruce Wayne did
and there's so much demand for Bruce
Wayne
return you know because the truth is the
definitive you know these are the
footage of character you know I kilgrave
is purple he's gonna be purple in the TV
show yeah no one could replace Batman um
how would i have written Matthew Malloy
Oh God that's a good question you know
probably should have ended the video
that way like here's how I would have
ended it you know the problem with a
character like that and I imaginary
business is not a bad writer and you
know if it came across and I was saying
that in the video that was not my
intention bindus is an amazing writer
he's got incredible stories under his
belt you know like like Sal for example
will swear by a by a Leah sound will
tell you with his dying breath then
alias is one of the greatest shows about
one of the greatest comics of all time
he'll take that you'll take that to the
grave you know I I think that his back
was up against the wall you know I think
that what he wanted to do was create a
character that was unique that was my
guess maybe not really made but a
character that was interesting but it
had to be self-contained because the
multiverse was coming to an end you know
and and even then within the confines of
the story you know how do you write a
character that continues on with such
extreme power you know I would have
truthfully I would have written him out
of the planet like I would have written
him out of planet Earth and I would have
made him into a cosmic entity you know I
would have said this guy's how are so
extreme you know that you know I guess
him as a character Matthew Malloy would
have been like you know I'm great I'm
destined for bigger and better things
you know and and kind of write him off
you know out of the story and then
eventually comes into contact with
Celestials or something like that and
the solutions were like you know you you
know we were making you one of us or
something along those lines you know
something to that effect having said
that you know if knowing Matthew Malloy
exists now despite the fact that he was
introduced after the incursion started
and after I guess before dr. doom was
announced you know the Hickman story was
great in and of itself it's probably one
of them the greatest stories ever told
in terms of like you know time runs out
and the lead-up to the end of the
multiverse I think it would have been
cool to have it circulate around Matthew
Malloy you know the Matthew Malloy you
know destroys the earth-616 reality or
something like that you know or destroys
it if of reality
and starts the chain of reactions or his
power so extreme that he basically like
initiates a chain reaction that ends
everything I don't know you know or he
you know he represents a reality in and
of itself he destroyed eternity which
returned wiped out that reality you know
I don't know but but either way you know
I think it'd take a little bit of
thinking you know I mean it'sit's when
it comes to writing stories guys and
especially when it comes to finishing
off stories you know it's not as simple
as you know here's what we do and then
just ending it like that you know
because it's it's tough so are you my
joined dragon ball super Rob absolutely
if Jim Carrey was to play someone in the
MCU who would it be Oh God um Jim Carrey
were to play somebody in the MCU I don't
know I'll top my head that would take
some thinking like that would take some
thinking um did you enjoy just the
family yes on a scale of 10 to 15 how
many babes do you get on that bed every
month come on you know better than ask a
question like that I will say this
though get the guitar the guitar plays
the guitar always plays let's see Jim
Carrey now that wouldn't be good as
carnage should be too weird I guess
would be is like a crazy person but
there are better people to play a crazy
person than Jim Carrey what are your pc
specs I have an i7 59 60 x 32 gigabytes
of memory a gtx titan x yeah the
memories running at 2133 megahertz
kickers whatever it is but yeah so um
somebody sent a message on okay um let's
see Rob confirmed a ladies man who would
win in a winner photo/matthew my boy
would obliterate the century no
questions asked what's your favorite new
52 Batman story Oh
new 52 Batman favorite story quarter
pals and night of Alice hands down and
here's why here's why quarter val is an
Ida bowels is my favorite story in new
52 Batman up until that point and we
covered this in that video up until that
point Batman's villains were run of the
middle and Batman knew their motivations
he knew where they operated out of
sometimes it was more beneficial to him
not to directly go and shut down the
penguin but to let the penguin engage in
his action so they could catch a bigger
fish and bring down the penguin at the
same time you know he knew where to face
operated out of and while they would
change their locations to time the time
at the end of the day he always knew
where to find them you know facing those
villains over the course of his
publication history Batman knew
everything about Gotham City with the
court of owls it went that way with
court of owls you know he came across a
group that had existed and Gotham under
his nose and he never knew about it it
basically destroyed the belief that
Batman knows everything about Gotham
City and that I think is one of the
coolest reasons why it was so beneficial
um let's see danti editor is carnage and
and the editor I like how this year all
same form Danny editor has a huge fan
following it some nuts people love dad
it's weird um let's see and it was the
only good thing about new 52 not by a
long shot there were some great things
around new pic you too um let's see
world breaker hope vs Thanos uh that's a
good one I'd say well Greg her whole
probably I mean will he be able to
pummel Thanos he can't kill him because
Thanos is immortal he can't die how do i
believe the secret wars battle world
storyline will end oh man
I think it'll end with the beyond her
energy dispersing creating a new
multiverse I think doom will be
destroyed I think doom being destroyed
brings an end to the Fantastic Four like
that ends that from that on that point
out Marvel can go forward and saying
Fantastic Four is gone forever we're
never bringing them back and with doom
gone there's never any chance of the
level reform I think that molecule man
Owen Reese will become the new Galactus
I think that battle world will be
destroyed in its entirety and then the
universe's will start to form themselves
after that the earth of 6 16 Scott new
to a reform where that's what they call
it you know though I think what they'll
do is they'll give us like a line by at
least I hope they'll give us a line by
line listing of all the realities like
here's this reality here's that reality
so on and so forth give us each of those
I would hope so but you know like like
okay Sal made a really good point during
the weekly pool podcast you know he said
that now is the perfect time for Marvel
to be writing a like a Bible for their
comics you know with going forward after
Secret Wars it's like the definitive
Bible every single character you know
starting with Secret Wars you know Miles
Morales Peter Parker that cast on a
force Carol Danvers the various members
of The Carol Carol core you know all
that stuff like make character profiles
like a Bible on those characters here's
everything you need to know in a 500
page book you know that tells you
everything about Marvel going forward
yeah that would be an awesome idea but
we'll see what happens Oh doom will not
die it's been confirmed that sex well I
guess it wasn't really sucked but I
don't know um let's easier if she said
yeah that set up for the new shut off of
Houston thank you um let's see hi Rob if
doom create a better world from the
multiverse how did the pieces of the
zombie world and Ultron world why could
I don't know I have no idea maybe
they'll explain maybe they won't i don't
i don't know let's see a team kappa team
Iron Man for Civil War I am
spider-man needs to be in the MCU he
will be like he's definitely gonna be in
the MCU he's getting a movie like they
pushed a bunch of movies back to make
room for his movie um man you should do
a superhero cartoon I don't know about
that can you get part of my underwear
that's weird do you know who watches
your channel now I don't know who all
watches my channel I know like you guys
and normal fans watch my channel but I
don't know who watched my videos user
doesn't let me see like the individual
channels that watch my video i watch
each one of my videos on second somebody
has a question about light sabers I love
lightsabers if you have a lightsaber how
would you how would I make it oh god if
i could have a lightsaber man i'd have
the most o P lightsaber okay here's my
question to you guys how many of you all
play star wars knights of the old
republic that's my question because
there were some o P lightsabers like my
lifesaver would be Viridian lucky would
be the Viridian color lightsaber which
was like an awesome like silverish green
color and then like you would be a lie
be light side you know I'd be on the
light side of the force and so my my
lights and would give me the ability to
temporarily like corrupt the Wills the
dark side and then make it easier to
kill him having said that like you
wouldn't be overpowered in the sense
that it would like break them you know
destroy likes if lightsabers that
wouldn't be very cool you know um let's
see ah you played it yeah yeah see all
you guys played it let guys know what's
up yeah snow what's up Star Wars ice the
old republic was amazing yeah I don't
yeah i have it on steam i guess such a
good game um metal Republic was insane
yes I was I were getting so swept up in
that game when it first came out like I
spent so much time playing it who's
going to fight in civil war and where is
oh I have no idea where whole cousin so
where's on earth somewhere probably in
hiding
um The Walking Dead versus the comics
portion of the show was a weekly series
but it'll stop once we get to the get to
the community you know it's just is on
the kind of cover stuff is just a side
project that I had going on let's see
favorite weapons of choice lightsaber
the green turtle shell and the bomb all
those are your favor wimp is no choice
okay that's cool um Adam warlock solo
book I am he'll probably get one when it
gets closer to two which we call it to
civil war but Vargas to infinity war but
I don't think you'll get one until then
let's see uh are you play metal gear no
I'm not playing metal gear you guys are
okay do you think Ultron's conclusion
the time travel and stuff it's lazy
storytelling to I'm curious because it
leads up to the multi now here's this
here's the thing guys like when it comes
to like age of Ultron like those those
big crossover events like um basically
everything from age of Ultron going
forward age of Ultron Avengers vs. x-men
all that kind of stuff like like all
those stories original sin all those
went towards Secret Wars like they were
all building up to Secret Wars and so
they all ended a very particular way
like I wouldn't say it was the lazy
story time there's some who will there's
some that say that that that story was
absolute garbage but I don't think it
was you know I thought it was a pretty
well told story I thought was pretty fun
to read do i watch Avengers Assemble now
do I think the one of evolved ever ever
be in the MCU now I doubt that Rob
please I only buy trades on your
recommendation which justice leaves are
worth buying ooh ok ok so Justice League
Justice League is is a mishmash really
there's you don't really you don't need
to buy everything on Justice League you
don't need to be no not by a long shot
by the trades for issues 1 through 6 or
i guess the trades for dark sides up
here it's like that's basically what it
is like this issues 1 through 6 maybe 1
through 7 t able to find that trade
somewhere and then stop and that's all
you need
for Darkseid Wars and all that kind of
stuff that's the only thing you need so
just go with that you know and then just
literally jump into dark side war you'll
find out everything you need to know as
it progresses let's see superboy prime
vs doomsday superboy-prime definitely
let's see what I rather have the force
the force source or be a Super Saiyan oh
I take the force any day of the week
let's see what games do you own at the
moment ah destiny Skyrim and then
whatever games i have on Steam see
favorite member of the Justice League
Green Lantern Hal Jordan like I love the
ability to create things using a ring to
use my imagination to create all those
different things so who's your all
favorite character the Justice League
that's a good question for you guys
who's your favorite character in the
Justice League let's see favorite comic
artist jaylee jamie has the best comic
art on the face of the planet is
abstract but it's it's like dark at the
same time like don't read the century 55
issue or six issue limited series
whatever it is that's Julie's art and it
is unbelievable actually here let me let
me find some of jellies are for you guys
it's it's actually pretty spectacular
god this the song is amazing chili art
it's it's a really cool looking here you
go the art of jelly he's got his own
website artwork
we go
the art of jelly um yeah but Batman
Martian Manhunter Wow Charmander
Charmander would be a beastly member of
the Justice League do I think Green
Lantern will ever appear on flash and
arrow I hope so because we've we've seen
Coast City mentioned before like we know
it exists so like we've we've seen the
sign for that city so we know that Hal
Jordan exists within that reality I hope
I'll see you i hope we seem in the
future you know i hope we see something
later on down the line i love we will or
not but i still think it'd be a really
cool idea let's see do you think we
should get a Star Wars Marvel heroes
comic we would get to Star Wars or like
a crossover between Star Wars in the
Marvel comic I doubt it I doubt we'll
see that I may be cool if we did I don't
think you all let's see who will fight
Doctor Doom at the end of sigur wars
also okay we've already talked about
talked about secret words already what
do you think will be in the Deadpool
movie what we got you got Ajax I'll top
my head and Ajax was a short-lived
character he only lasted for like 17
issues or something like that he wasn't
in a very long actually but he was a
main foam daredevil or is of Deadpool in
his first first series under am under um
man Joe Kelly there we go my mind just
he was Deadpool's main enemy under Joe
Kelly I mean you got copycat you got
let's see um yeah it looks like it's
gonna be based on Joe Kelly's character
Joe Kelly's one of the character um all
the characters are popped up in there
look like they're going to be part of it
I don't think we'll see mistress death
or anything like that yet I think we'll
see some cool stuff but yeah I don't
think we'll see like mistress death or
anything along those lines you know
having said that that movie is going to
explode and it's going to do really
really well and Marvel needs to find a
way to get Deadpool into the marvel
cinematic universe because could you
imagine that could you imagine Deadpool
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
wouldn't that be hilarious like the
Avengers are fighting or there's some
major conflict in Captain America 3 and
Deadpool like shows up after the fights
over you know like that'd be hilarious
are you gonna be reading the new
squadron supreme series not a chance
let's see um ever had a fight yeah I
used to get in fights when I was a kid I
mean not routinely but you know when I
was when I was a kid back when we were
younger and I think there's something to
be said about how far school systems
have changed over the years but when I
was a kid you know when I was in Middle
School like it school was like prison
like he had to go in there and he had to
immediately establish that people
couldn't give you a hard time you know
doesn't mean you went in there picked a
fight immediately but it means that
somebody walked up on you and started
challenging you I get a stick up for
yourself you know and you had to fight
him you know you think favre in school
when you fought him after school you
know but you know that was that's that's
not things were when I was when I was
younger um let's see based on your
personality if you were in the lantern
corps which Lantern Corps would I be in
Oh God was ventricle would I be in man
which Lantern Corps would I be in
I'm gonna make a video about that just
for fun like all this premise that must
be like you know what guys this video is
just for fun like I'm gonna make a video
about that you know which Lantern Corps
would I choose which Lantern Corps would
you be in is what we would all title it
and get y'all's opinion on on what you
guys think like which electric where you
would join we're gonna we're gonna wait
for that one question got answered won't
see I'm and why do you think that amazes
me how come you guys get so surprised
when you when you guys show up to a
weekly Q&A and your question gets
answered your kind of blows me away I
can show you because I don't have time
to answer every single question but you
know that I win the fights we have once
the flights and I lost some fights and
it knows the issue okay look guys
fighting is never an answer to solving
your problems the issue was letting
people know you weren't a person that
could be mess around with their easily
picked on you know establishing like you
as a person stood up for yourself
regardless of the circumstances that you
always made sure people knew that you
had confidence in yourself you know that
that's what it was about it was building
confidence you know dealing with dealing
with bullies you know whether it's
dealing with them right now you know or
whether it is you know I guess dealing
with him with the way they're done now
in terms of like you know trying to
rationalize with them or something like
that or whether it was the way it was
done when I was a kid you know in
finding them it's not about physical
force it's about confidence because as
you grow when you deal with bullies when
you face bullies it gives you the
confidence to know that you can face
situations that are otherwise daunting
and overwhelming that's the purpose of
confronting bullies it's not about
fighting them it's not about beating
them up that's the other half measure
you know it's about building confidence
in yourself and giving yourself the
belief that you can face almost anything
uh let's see because a celebrity
answered you're quite a celebrity by a
long shot I don't know what you get to
talk it robson pie notice me who will
fight will rain an old man Logan in the
old man Logan batesville I don't know
but I'm really really excited for that
um I'm they're not going to have the
Hulk obviously they're not be able to
feature his character just because you
know Fox has nothing to do with the Hulk
you know it's I don't know i mean
honestly I have no earthly clue magneto
maybe but it's hard to tell you know
because they haven't really focused I
mean they bad like silver samurai you
know but that's silver samurai from the
comet or from the movie you know will
rain origins what's garbage you know and
so I have no idea what they're gonna be
doing now they haven't really focused on
Wolverines rogues gallery you know they
haven't focus on this individual
villains maybe they will you know I have
no idea but um you I play Magic the
Gathering know how they played the new
destiny expansion yes um do you like
Debbie cakes hell yeah I do let me tell
you man does not get to my girth by
eating healthy you think you might be a
blue lantern that's awesome uh let's see
trying to watch it but faster the
furious I came down with a cold after I
got back from Los Angeles so that sucks
um how old were you when you got your
first comic 11 Rob in the new reboot are
there going to be multiverses again or
just 616 there's going to be multiverses
they're going to be different different
universes let's see how do you feel
about a whole kills the marvel universe
story I would read the hell out of that
story Hulk kills the marvel universe
definitely let's see who should play
Blue Beetle and booster gold in the DC
movie
it should be silly okay Jim Carrey could
play one of the character he could play
like like Blue Beetle and then Booster
Gold I have no idea um let's see no yeah
no I don't play it I don't play magic
what do you think of Michael Jai White
playing cyborg he's the same guy that
played spawn no he's too old to play
cyborg you know cyborg needs to be a
younger character if we were talking
about flashpoint sideboard sure but and
I'd say no not by a long shot chrono
trigger for the win yes chrono trigger
was so good Colonel cross was really
good too any of you guys ever played
that game it was the PlayStation sequel
to chrono trigger biggest difference
between miss marvel a captain marvel
well captain bubble gained her powers
from the site magnetron which basically
made it so that she had all the same
powers as Marvel of the Kree miss Marvel
isn't a human who was looking at woken
up who gained her in human abilities as
a result of the Terrigen mists expanding
throughout the world from the fallout of
infinity and inhumanity and she'd on the
outfit of miss marvel or I guess she
adopted the name miss marvel because she
idolized Carol Danvers
what am I going to read post secret wars
I'm gonna pick up everything at first
i'm gonna read everything right off the
bat houses gym going it cranking along
as always sup Rob what's up what do you
think of infinity Ghana for um I were
ready yet to be honest let's see how do
you feel about foxes version of
Apocalypse he looks fine to me okay look
guys he wasn't he was covered in purple
like if you look at the newer images now
he's blue like imagine that people were
freaking out like oh my god you know
like they they were so focused on the
fact that he looked purple they didn't
take the time to look at the picture and
realize that everybody in the picture
was purple which is kind of weird but um
let's see uh talk about Star Wars
explaining the difference between the
dark so oh don't worry guys like when we
get to towards December on Rob explains
you'll get more Star Wars content than
you can handle I promise you like it'll
be a star wars a month like there's
going to be so much Star Wars stuff
coming out of that the origin of the
Jedi the origin of the Sith the great
hyperspace war the first time they
fought um the lead up to watch imma call
it you know there's gonna be all kinds
of Star Wars counted on Rob explains
let's see who should be the villain in
spider-man movies honestly I don't want
to see the lizard I don't want to see
dr. octopus I don't god for god sake I
do not want to see the Green Goblin
Jesus Christ i'm so tired of seeing
Norman Osborn um Sandman would be a
great villain he's difficult to face
he's not a run-of-the-mill villain he's
solid you know what better than that
Mysterio I'd want to see Mysterio who do
you guys want to see for the spider-man
first my demands villain and the mobile
Cinematic Universe that's my question
like here do you guys want to shoot
a ps4 xbox one or PC will depends on the
game um pcs better for games like Skyrim
because there's so many mods um let's
see ps4 I like because of destiny and
xbox one I like because of Minecraft are
you gonna get Battlefront no I'm not
going to get battle friend let's see
Craven Wow some people want to see
Craven venom venom in car carnage would
be a good one the shocker what do you
think about agent venom a thousand dr.
strange right now Mysterio huh I never
really got into agent venom I never
really read much about agent venom never
got into his character ah let's see who
do you who would you like to play Jon
Stewart oh god you know that would be a
good role dead okay if I had it my way
like Idris Elba would play would play
Jon Stewart but you know he is part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and I
don't know how this contract works I
don't know if he I don't I don't know if
he signed a contract saying that he
can't go work for DC I have no idea if
he didn't and he can work for DC and
we're really not going to see him
anymore I which will probably see him in
Ragnarok but if we don't see him after
that I would say definitely have him
play Jon Stewart let's see uh what comic
book should i buy about Captain America
there's actually a comic book launching
right now called captain america white
which as far as I know deals with the
history of Captain America like it's
going to be the definitive Captain
America story also the death of Captain
America is really good let's see Metal
Gear Solid explaining the different
snakes um I may end up doing that I'm
Rob explain see the cool thing about Bob
explains guys is just kind of like this
catch-all you know it's it's like it's
like a Victorian TV basically like if
you guys don't know what comic story on
TV TV is s Benny's branch off from
comics Torian where it's kind of a
catch-all for a bunch of different
things what you guys should sub to what
he's trying to do he's trying to race to
100 subscriber hundred thousands
crabbers and he's gonna do a 24 hour
livestream if he gets to it so you guys
are definitely check that out but Rob
explains is is like my version of comic
story and TV basically you know it's
kind of a catch-all you know that that
encompasses a lot of different things so
silver sable like silver sable she's a
weird character let's see do you think
Marvel should reboot if so how would you
do it and what would you change where
they are they're doing it with a secret
wars let's see what a what's an awesome
Deadpool story to pick up the Deadpool
killa G Deadpool kills the marvel
universe Deadpool killa straighted and
deadpool kills deadpool those are
definitely worth checking out let's see
who should play Adam warlock um hmm I
don't know see that's the tough thing
about characters like the Adam warlock
characters like that it is difficult to
like take off the top of my head who
should play those because there's a lot
of different actors out there a lot of
whom were capable but some of whom were
terrible in truth for all intensive
purposes like I think Paul Bettany would
have been a really good Adam warlock but
he's playing the visioning of the vision
the vision he he's playing the vision so
it's it's that's difficult let's see
actually hey guys look it's it's it's
almost one-thirty um I need to finish
working on this Batman in-game video so
i can get that video out today but i'm
gonna grow grab some lunch I'm gonna
come back here finish working on that
video and yeah so I'm gonna bounce off
here thanks for joining thanks for
coming out again make sure you guys
check out Rob explains that of course
you'll find a you'll find a link in the
description but here is also the link in
case you guys are interested in checking
it out that's my channel where I
basically explained things outside of
comic books you know it's a kind of a
catch-all for a bunch of different stuff
Star Wars and Donald Trump and the
lightsaber colors and all different
kinds of stuff so make sure you guys
check that out and yeah I will catch you
guys later please
I think maybe oh wait a minute I left
the thing okay I'll be I'll be peacing
out here in a second here in a second
here shortly ah maybe kind of I forgot
okay peace